This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It's really hard to get a sound trademark. The first one in the US was issued in 1978 to NBC for their times. MGM has one for their roaring lion. As does 20th century Fox. That's 99PI's own Katie Mangle. After a year's of litigation, they finally withdrew their application. So if a bunch of burly bikers can't do it, it must be really hard.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。获得声音商标真的很难。美国第一个声音商标是在1978年颁发给NBC的，用于他们的报时。米高梅影业拥有他们那只咆哮狮子的声音商标。20世纪福克斯影业也有一个。那是99PI的凯蒂·明格尔。经过一年的诉讼，他们最终撤回了申请。所以，如果一群粗犷的摩托车手都做不到，那一定真的很难。
Right now, there are fewer than 200 active trademarks for sounds, even though sound can be super important to brand. Just ask these guys. My name is Joel Beckerman, and I'm Tyler Gray. Tyler and I wrote a book called The Sonic Boom, How Sound Transforms the Way We Think, Feel, and Buy. Here's a sound that would be, like, impossible to trademark. But Tyler and Joel say it was crucial to building up the brand it's associated with. Oh man, I know that sound. I know it so well.
目前，有效的各种声音商标不到200个，尽管声音对品牌来说可能非常重要。问问这些人就知道了。我叫乔尔·贝克曼，我是泰勒·格雷。泰勒和我写了一本书，叫《音爆：声音如何改变我们的思维、感受和购买方式》。这是一个听起来几乎不可能注册商标的声音。但泰勒和乔尔说，它对于建立与之相关的品牌至关重要。天哪，我知道那个声音。我太熟悉了。
When I was just a little kid on a cul-de-sac, they built a chillies in my town. This was before there were really chain restaurants where I lived, so chiles actually felt kind of novel and exotic. My family was pumped and our favorite thing to order is fajitas. They don't really sell the steak, they sell the sizzle. In their book Joel and Tyler used chiles and their sizzling fajitas as an opening example to illustrate why companies should think more about sound. You're sitting in a chiles at the dinner hour at 5 o'clock and let's say at first nobody's ordering the sizzling fajitas, but then maybe about 20 minutes, 30 minutes into the dinner hour and I've seen this. All of a sudden one person orders sizzling fajitas.
当我还是个住在死胡同里的小孩时，他们在我镇上建了一家辣椒餐厅（Chili's）。那是在我住的地方还没有连锁餐厅的时候，所以辣椒餐厅对我来说其实感觉挺新奇、挺异域的。我家人很兴奋，我们最喜欢点的就是法希塔（墨西哥烤肉）。他们卖的其实不是牛排，而是滋滋作响的声音。在他们的书中，乔尔和泰勒用辣椒餐厅和他们滋滋作响的法希塔作为开篇例子，来说明为什么公司应该更多地考虑声音。假设你在晚餐时间5点坐在辣椒餐厅里，起初没人点滋滋作响的法希塔，但可能在晚餐时间过了20到30分钟后，我见过这种情况。突然间，有一个人点了滋滋作响的法希塔。
As the server brings out the sizzling skillet of fajita, meat and onions. And you hear that sizzling sound literally every eye, every single person in that restaurant. Their head turns to the server, walking past them, and they follow that server with their eyes, and then they smell the burnt onions, and now you're hooked. And now everyone orders a sizzling fajita. And in the back, instead of making that one order, they make 15. Yeah, they call it the fajita effect. My family fell victim to the fajita effect too many times to remember.
当服务员端出滋滋作响的法希塔铁板，上面有肉和洋葱时。你听到了那滋滋声，真的，餐厅里的每一双眼睛，每一个人。他们的头都会转向走过身边的服务员，用目光追随那个服务员，然后他们闻到了焦洋葱的味道，现在你被吸引住了。于是每个人都点了滋滋作响的法希塔。在后厨，他们不再只做那一份，而是做了15份。是的，他们称之为“法希塔效应”。我的家人也曾多次成为“法希塔效应”的受害者。
We may even have initiated the original fajita effect, patient zero of the fajita effect. Chili's, by the way, did not original fajita effect, patient zero of the fajita effect. Chilis, by the way, did not invent fajita. That distinction goes to a Texan by the name of Sonny Falcone. He was selling a subpar cut a meat called the Faha and figured that if you cooked it out in the open with a lot of spice, people didn't care about the quality of the meat. It got to chilis because Larry Levine… Larry Levine was the founder of the meat. It got to Chili's because Larry Levine... Larry Levine was the founder of Chili's. Had seen restaurants around the Rio Grande Valley
我们甚至可能引发了最初的“法希塔效应”，是“法希塔效应”的零号病人。顺便说一下，辣椒餐厅并没有发明法希塔。这一殊荣属于一位名叫桑尼·法尔科内的德克萨斯人。他当时在卖一种次等的肉，叫Faha，他想如果他在露天用大量的香料烹饪它，人们就不会在意肉的质量了。它之所以传到辣椒餐厅，是因为拉里·莱文……拉里·莱文是辣椒餐厅的创始人。他曾看到格兰德河谷周围的餐馆
sort of do their version of it. He had the idea to make sound the star of the show. And so when Chili's opened up, they put that sound of sizzling fajitas in their first-ever commercial. fajitas sold like crazy. In the wake of their massive success, Chili's printed up t-shirts for staff that said,
以某种方式做出了他们的版本。他想到了让声音成为主角。所以当辣椒餐厅开业时，他们把法希塔滋滋作响的声音放进了他们的第一个广告里。法希塔卖疯了。在他们取得巨大成功之后，辣椒餐厅为员工印制了T恤，上面写着：
I survived the summer of Fahida madness. Now they serve enough fajita meat to fill two nuclear submarines a year. I really hope someone filled two nuclear submarines with fajita meat to get that measurement. Tyler and Joel say it's surprisingly difficult to get people, even really creative people, to think about sound, to value it in the same way they value the visual environment. But sometimes there's one person who gets it. At Apple Computers, one of those people was a guy by the name of Jim Reeks. Hi, my name is Jim Reeks.
“我在法希塔狂热的夏天幸存下来”。现在他们供应的法希塔肉足以每年填满两艘核潜艇。我真希望有人真的用法希塔肉填满了两艘核潜艇来得出这个测量结果。泰勒和乔尔说，让人们，甚至是极具创造力的人去思考声音，像重视视觉环境一样重视声音，这出奇地困难。但有时总有一个人能理解。在苹果电脑公司，其中一个人叫吉姆·里克斯。嗨，我叫吉姆·里克斯。
I am the only person you know whose name is a complete sentence. Jim worked at Apple for about 10 years starting in the late 80s. We didn't really have titles. I don't even think I had business cards. Well, whatever his title was, Jim was working on sound for the Macintosh computers. Which was a neglected stepchild of all things Mac. No one really cared about the sound until the end, which is unfortunately typical. Except Jim. He's a composer and a musician, and he understood the importance of sound more than most of his colleagues. And Jim had strong feelings about the startup sound that was on the Mac at the time. I just hated it. I just could not stand it.
我是你认识的人中唯一一个名字就是完整句子的人。吉姆在苹果工作了大约10年，从80年代末开始。我们其实没有头衔。我甚至不记得我有过名片。好吧，不管他的头衔是什么，吉姆当时正在为麦金塔电脑制作声音。那是所有Mac产品中被忽视的继子。没人真正关心声音，直到最后，这不幸地很典型。除了吉姆。他是一位作曲家和音乐家，他比大多数同事都更了解声音的重要性。而且吉姆对当时Mac上的启动声音有强烈的看法。我只是讨厌它。我简直无法忍受。
Here's what it sounded like. Here is a couple more times because it goes by really fast. So when Apple first started up, it was, you know, the computer was far from perfect. It crashed a lot. And every time you turned it back on, you heard that jolting sound. So Jim set out to make a better one. You're Mac just crashed. Again. You've lost your work. Again. You're waiting for this thing to boot up. Again. That's the audience. Just a bunch of pissed off, frustrated people who are super annoyed and you're wasting their time.
这是它听起来的样子。再听几次，因为它过得太快了。所以当苹果刚起步时，你知道，电脑远非完美。它经常死机。每次你重新打开它，你都会听到那种刺耳的声音。所以吉姆着手制作一个更好的声音。你的Mac又死机了。又一次。你又丢失了工作。又一次。你又在等这东西启动。又一次。那是听众。只是一群愤怒、沮丧、超级烦躁的人，你在浪费他们的时间。
That's a hard audience to play too. I got to change everyone's mood, so I was thinking a zan-like, meditative sound, similar to a gong, or chanting own. Of course, we're all familiar with the sound he came up with. Oh that's nice. So much better right? Only problem was Jim asked for permission to put this new sound into the prototype for the new Mac and... I was told I couldn't do it. We already have a sound, you're not allowed to change it, it was just on and on and on. But Jim knew the people who were responsible for building the prototype.
那是一个很难取悦的听众。我得改变每个人的心情，所以我想到了一种禅宗般的、冥想的声音，类似于锣声，或者吟唱的“嗡”声。当然，我们都熟悉他想出的那个声音。哦，那真好。好多了，对吧？唯一的问题是，吉姆请求许可将这个新声音放入新Mac的原型机中，然后……我被告知我不能这样做。我们已经有了一个声音，你不允许改变它，就是这样没完没了。但吉姆认识负责制造原型机的人。
I played it for them and then they liked it and so when no one was around, we put it into the build and the Quadro 700 shipped with the sound in it. That was back in 1991 when the Quadra 700 Mac costs $6,000. Jim says he never got any props for the sound. Just grief. And yet, that sound with a few minor tweaks has been the Apple startup sound ever since. So I think we can assume that Steve Jobs liked it. It's this big giant two-handed C-Cord, C-Major Cord,
我给他们播放了它，他们很喜欢，所以当没人在场时，我们把它放进了构建版本中，Quadro 700就带着这个声音出厂了。那是1991年的事了，当时Quadra 700 Mac售价6000美元。吉姆说他从未因这个声音得到任何赞誉。只有痛苦。然而，那个声音经过几次微小的调整，就成了苹果此后的启动声音。所以我认为我们可以假设史蒂夫·乔布斯喜欢它。这是一个巨大的、双手弹奏的C大调和弦，
that makes you kind of feel welcome to this very stable, very substantial world of Apple. It's probably the single most connected sound with the Apple brand. And brand is just the experience or a perception prior to the experience. So everything that shapes the perception matters, you know, like imagine a really beautiful car that just had this horrible engine always backfiring. Actually, there are people who make sure that beautiful cars sound beautiful, or at least that they sound right. One of them is Sean Carney.
让你感到欢迎来到这个非常稳定、非常实质的苹果世界。它可能是与苹果品牌联系最紧密的声音。而品牌只是体验或体验之前的感知。所以塑造感知的每一件事都很重要，你知道，就像想象一辆非常漂亮的汽车，却总是发出可怕的引擎回火声。事实上，确实有人确保漂亮的汽车听起来很美，或者至少听起来是对的。其中之一就是肖恩·卡尼。
Hi, my name is Sean Carney. I'm a Mustang Power Train Sound Quality Engineer for Ford. Sean works on Mustangs, and there are all kinds of things he and his team can tweak to get the sound they're looking for. There's different tubes inside, but the exhaust gases will flow through, and those tubes have different shapes and different preparations, and only a different whole pattern. It's sort of like an instrument. Kind of like you can control the sound of a horn by placing your fingers over different holes. Sean can control the sound of the Mustang.
嗨，我叫肖恩·卡尼。我是福特野马动力总成音质工程师。肖恩负责野马汽车，他和他的团队可以调整各种东西来获得他们想要的声音。里面有不同的管子，排气会流过，这些管子有不同的形状和不同的准备，只有不同的孔模式。它有点像乐器。就像你可以通过把手指放在不同的孔上来控制喇叭的声音一样。肖恩可以控制野马的声音。
And it's an easier job for the standard V8. But then sometimes they'll put out a specialty Mustang. In 2008, Mustang decided to put out a remake of a Mustang that appeared in the movie Bullet in 1968. In the movie, there's a pretty famous chase sequence where Steve McQueen drives his Mustang all over the streets of San Francisco. Mustang all over the streets of San Francisco.
对于标准的V8引擎来说，这是一项更容易的工作。但有时他们会推出一款特别版的野马。2008年，野马决定推出一款1968年电影《警网铁金刚》（Bullitt）中出现的野马的翻拍版。在电影中，有一段非常著名的追逐戏，史蒂夫·麦奎因驾驶他的野马在旧金山的街道上飞驰。在旧金山的街道上飞驰。
Sean and his team wanted to make the 2008 bullet sound similar to the 1968 bullet. So when it comes to a car and it's about an old car from old movie. So yeah, we're trying to make that specific car to be too in a way and it's drawing you back into those old memories. It's almost like that folklore of what that car might have been. They're trying essentially to make a new car sound old, which is challenging because cars made in 1968 were built completely differently. That engine had a carburetor, we used a fuel injection system, and all of the things, they completely changed how the engine can sound.
肖恩和他的团队想让2008年的Bullitt听起来类似于1968年的Bullitt。所以当谈到汽车，而且是关于老电影里的老车时。所以是的，我们试图让那辆特定的车以某种方式重现，它把你拉回了那些旧记忆中。这几乎就像那辆车可能是什么样的民间传说。他们本质上是在试图让一辆新车听起来像旧车，这很有挑战性，因为1968年制造的汽车建造方式完全不同。那个引擎有化油器，我们使用了燃油喷射系统，所有这些东西，它们完全改变了引擎的声音。
Sean was never going to be able to duplicate the sound of the bullet car from the movie exactly. For one, the Mustang in the movie was enhanced, with sounds recorded from a race car. And apart from that, it's actually illegal in most places to drive around in a car that loud. So a big part of what we try to do is we try to identify what are those key characteristics and what are the notes that are being played by that classic American V8 sound that's in the movie.
肖恩永远无法完全复制电影中Bullitt汽车的声音。首先，电影中的野马经过了增强，录制了赛车的声音。除此之外，在大多数地方驾驶那么吵的汽车实际上是违法的。所以我们尝试做的一大部分工作是，我们试图识别那些关键特征是什么，以及电影中那种经典的美国V8声音所演奏的音符是什么。
When the reviews of the bullet Mustang came out, people talked about the sound. And most people thought Sean and his team had gotten it right. Here's the 2008 bullet Mustang in action. Sound is actually in terms of all of our senses, it's the one we react to quickest, it's even quicker than touch. That's Joel Beckerman again. Brands that are not paying attention to this, not paying attention to sound and association with experiences,
当Bullitt野马的评论出来时，人们谈论了它的声音。大多数人认为肖恩和他的团队做对了。这是2008年Bullitt野马的实际表现。声音实际上是我们所有感官中反应最快的一个，它甚至比触觉还要快。那是乔尔·贝克曼。那些不注意这一点，不注意声音和体验关联的品牌，
they're really going to get punished. Case in point, in 2010, Frito Leigh decided to come out with a new, biodegradable, sun chips bag. Only problem was, they never considered what that packaging sounded like. Here's a YouTube video, someone made about the bag. Only problem was they never considered what that packaging sounded like. Here's a YouTube video someone made about the bag. Delicious sun chips love all your products. Think that I cannot get over. Is the noise that this bag makes? I don't know what it's made out of. If you ever wanted to get like this one little chip out of the bag. And actually, you know, and I usually can't even. You want to get one chip out of this bag. Good luck.
他们真的会受到惩罚。举个例子，2010年，菲多利（Frito-Lay）决定推出一种新的、可生物降解的太阳薯片（Sun Chips）袋子。唯一的问题是，他们从未考虑过那种包装听起来是什么样的。这是一个YouTube视频，有人制作了关于这个袋子的视频。唯一的问题是他们从未考虑过那种包装听起来是什么样的。这是一个YouTube视频，有人制作了关于这个袋子的视频。美味的太阳薯片，喜欢你们所有的产品。我无法克服的一点是。这个袋子发出的噪音。我不知道它是用什么做的。如果你曾经想从袋子里拿出这一小片薯片。而且实际上，你知道，我通常甚至不能。你想从这个袋子里拿出一片薯片。祝你好运。
That guy on YouTube was not the only person to notice how noisy the bag was. Someone created a Facebook page called, sorry, I can't hear you over this sun chips bag, and it got 40,000 likes, and it became a national news story. They had to pull the new bag and go back to the old back. Good intentions, bad execution.
YouTube上的那个人并不是唯一注意到袋子有多吵的人。有人创建了一个Facebook页面，叫“抱歉，我听不见你说话，因为这个太阳薯片袋子太吵了”，它获得了4万个赞，并成为了全国性的新闻故事。他们不得不撤回新袋子，换回旧袋子。良好的意图，糟糕的执行。
Joel and Tyler refer to this kind of sound as a sonic trash. You know, you'd never let somebody take a bunch of trash and throw it in your front lawn. But we allow cities, our neighbors, brands to really invade our sonic space. It dump garbage in your ear. Essentially. Essentially.
乔尔和泰勒把这种声音称为“声音垃圾”。你知道，你永远不会让别人把一堆垃圾扔在你的前草坪上。但我们允许城市、我们的邻居、品牌真正侵入我们的声音空间。本质上是在你的耳朵里倾倒垃圾。本质上。
Joule and Tyler, imagine a world where all the sounds we hear have more thought behind them, more intention. It would be very rare that you would actually hear the sound that something made. That thing would trigger a better sound. In Tyler's world, they could make the sun chips bag sound like this when it's open. Every time you get a chip, you're like, Yeah, except that sound. It's actually on that very short list of trademark sounds.
乔尔和泰勒想象一个世界，我们听到的所有声音背后都有更多的思考，更多的意图。你实际上听到某种东西发出的声音是非常罕见的。那个东西会触发一个更好的声音。在泰勒的世界里，他们可以让太阳薯片袋子在打开时听起来像这样。每次你拿一片薯片，你都会觉得，耶，除了那个声音。它实际上在那个非常短的商标声音列表中。
So hands off. Whatever. Whatever. 99% Invisible With Produces Week by Katie Mingle with Sam Greenspan, Avery, Truppleman, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW and San Francisco introduced of the offices of Oxon, an architecture and interiors firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. I hope when I die, there's a button on my tombstone and you can press it and it would play the sound. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook,
所以别碰它。随便吧。随便吧。《99%隐形》，由凯蒂·明格尔制作，山姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特鲁普曼和我罗曼·马斯参与。我们是91.7本地公共广播电台KALW和旧金山的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心Oxon建筑和室内设计公司的办公室里录制。我希望当我死后，我的墓碑上有一个按钮，你可以按一下，它就会播放那个声音。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并点赞，
I tweet at Roman Mars, we also have a cool tumbler and a Spotify playlist that will provide a nice soundtrack to your workday. But I encourage you to explore the entire world of 99% invisible at 99pi.org. Radio to be out. From PRX. PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我在推特上是@RomanMars，我们还有一个很酷的Tumblr和一个Spotify播放列表，将为你的工作日提供美妙的配乐。但我鼓励你探索《99%隐形》的整个世界，网址是99pi.org。广播电台。来自PRX。PRX。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。